On March 8th,
Irish citizens will be asked to vote in a one
but two referendums.
But what exactly is the referendum?
It's a national vote on a particular issue
to potentially change the constitution
or Bunrock Nahheron.
The constitution was enacted in 1937
and sets out how Arlin should be governed
and the rights of its citizens.
But it has evolved since then
and has been changed 32 times.
But it's not possible to add,
delete or edit anything in ish
without asking the citizens in a vote first.
Another word
a referendum.
The politicians come up with a question
and it's up to the people to say yes or no.
How does a pass if more than 50% of voters say yes?
If more than 50% say no,
the Constitution stays as it is.
To vote in the upcoming referendums
you will need to be 18 or over
on March the 8th,
an Irish citizen
and registered to vote
to have your say.